[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Getting started
with Google Cloud Platform.
Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL is a fully-managed
database service
that makes it easy to
set up, maintain, manage,
and administer your relational
database in the cloud.
Cloud SQL offers high
performance, scalability,
and convenience, providing
a database infrastructure
for applications
running anywhere.
To get started with
Cloud SQL, first
go to the Cloud SQL Instances
page in the Google Cloud
Platform console, and
select your project.
Next, click Create Instance.
Click MySQL, and choose
Second Generation.
Enter My Instance
for the instance ID,
and a password
for the root user.
You can use default values
for the other fields,
and click Create.
You'll return to
the instances list.
Your new instance is
grayed out while it
initializes and starts up.
We can now connect
to your instance
using the MySQL client
in the Cloud Shell.
In the Google Cloud
platform console,
click the Cloud Shell icon
in the upper right corner.
At the Cloud Shell prompt,
connect to your Cloud SQL
instance and enter
your root password.
You should now see
the MySQL prompt.
Now that we're connected,
we can perform operations
on the database.
Create a SQL database on
your Cloud SQL instance
by typing create
database guestbook.
Insert sample data into
the guestbook database.
And retrieve the data
by selecting select star
from entries.
Congratulations.
You've successfully created
a Cloud SQL instance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]